170,000 U.S. military personnel
are deployed overseas.
Of them, about sixty-thousand, or 35%, are
stationed in Japan — more than any other country.
In fact, only two — Germany and
South Korea — even come close.
And while this number has been
slowly declining in most places,
troop deployments in Japan
are actually on the rise.
Its islands are home to over 80 American bases
and the Navy’s only forward-deployed
aircraft carrier, USS Ronald Reagan.
The U.S.-Japan alliance is among
the strongest in the world.
In the last century, Japanese
leaders have made more State,
Official, and Official Working visits
to the U.S. than any other ally.
The public in both countries also overwhelmingly
view the other favorably — 71%
of Japanese and 87% of Americans.
Yet there has always been a
fundamental sense of imbalance.
The United States is, unquestionably,
Japan’s closest ally. But Japan is
only one of many close American allies.
One needs the other for its continued existence,
whereas the other only wants
the benefit of cooperation.
For being friends, the two countries exchange
a whole lot of money, leading many to wonder:
“Who gets the better deal?”
Sponsored by CuriosityStream and
Nebula — where you can watch this bonus video
about Japan’s almost-nuclear deterrence.
The relationship between the U.S.
and Japan has never been “normal”.
Unlike NATO allies, who are
committed to defending one another,
theirs is one-sided. While the
U.S. is bound to protect Japan,
which it accomplishes through extended
nuclear deterrence, the reverse is not true.
Instead, the arrangement began as a strategic
trade — security in exchange for bases,
which gave the American military
a front-row seat in Asia.
It was agreed that Japan would provide
all the facilities, airfields, and ports,
while the U.S. would pay for everything else.
At the time, all this seemed perfectly fair.
Japan, after all, was then
completely devastated by the war.
In fact, it could very easily be argued
that, as the victor, the U.S. took advantage.
As time went on, however, Japan only got richer
and richer. So too did the Yen gain in value.
The circumstances had changed
dramatically, yet the deal had not.
And so, under pressure from the Americans, in 1978
Japan began making payments above and
beyond what was required by the treaty.
Because these payments were designed to
demonstrate understanding for the costs — monetary
and otherwise — shouldered by the Americans,
they became known as the “Sympathy Budget”.
The U.S. prefers the term “Host-Nation Support”.
While making clear this was completely voluntary,
Japan built new facilities, paid their utilities,
and covered the salaries of its
citizens who worked in them.
Then two things happened which
raised concerns of loyalty.
First, Japan refused to help secure the
Persian Gulf during the Iran-Iraq war,
despite being explicitly
asked to do so by the U.S.
And second, Toshiba was caught around the same
time selling military technology to the Soviets.
The country was at serious risk of being seen
as a bad ally. It knew it had to do something.
That something turned out to be formalizing
the previously-voluntary annual payments
into contracts called Special Measure
Agreements, to be renegotiated every 5 years.
Japan’s contributions climbed
immediately to a new high.
In the 40 years between 1978 and 2016,
Japan paid something like $65 billion
in total for U.S. forces, with an
average increase of 17% a year.
In 2019, it contributed roughly $3.16 billion
to the U.S. military when everything from labor,
to utilities, the cost to relocate training
exercises away from civilian populations,
and facility upgrades are included.
But what do these numbers
really mean, you may wonder.
In 2017, Japanese politicians claimed the
country shoulders 86% of the total cost to
station U.S. troops there. The Pentagon came up
with 74% in 2004. Other sources go as low as 50%.
Whatever the true figure, it’s higher than
South Korea — around 40% — or Germany — 32.
None of these numbers, however, are complete.
Many contributions simply can’t be quantified.
These include things like indirect subsidies,
the infrastructure around bases,
like roads, waived taxes and fees,
and, quite substantially, the rents that could’ve
been collected from the land occupied by bases.
Last but not least, Japan buys nearly
all its defense equipment from the U.S.
The biggest sacrifice made
by the Japanese government,
however, is not monetary, but political.
Politicians are caught between
two very powerful forces.
On one side is the public, who
overwhelmingly opposes militarization.
Anything resembling an expansion of the
military will be met with intense scrutiny.
No party, no matter how popular, can
afford to ignore the will of voters
on this issue — which means very carefully
tip-toeing around the entire subject of defense.
In 2015, for instance, Shinzo Abe
passed a security law allowing the
military to protect its allies under certain
circumstances, in addition to self-defense — a
right so basic and universal that it’s
enshrined in the United Nations charter.
For this, he paid dearly — as you can
clearly see in this graph of approval rating.
On one day alone, 300 protests were
staged across the country — the
largest of which attracted 120,000 people.
Shinzo Abe’s relative success in politics
came despite his perceived “hawkishness”, not
because of it. In the run-up to elections,
he would cleverly shift focus to the economy,
only turning to defense after he had won.
On the other side is the United States.
In America, where no equivalent “peace
culture” exists, Japan’s unwillingness
to expand the size and role of its military
is not some noble commitment to Pacifism,
but somewhere between greedy and dangerous.
Many would like for it to take on a greater share
of the financial burden for the sake of fairness.
Others, including much of the
foreign policy establishment,
see Japan as relying too heavily on the
U.S., at the expense of its own military,
and ultimately, the security of
the entire Asia-Pacific region.
Thus, Japanese politicians must carefully
balance these two forces — in the short-term
satisfying the demands of voters or else losing
power, while simultaneously meeting the rising,
long-term expectations of its ally, or
else losing its sole source of protection.
This tension came to a head
during the First Gulf War.
In December 1990, the U.S. Ambassador called
the Japanese Prime Minister on the phone,
asking a longstanding ally for support
against the Iraqi invasion of Kuwait.
But doing so was deemed unconstitutional. In one
poll, just one third of respondents supported
sending forces, though with one (hilarious)
condition: that they would not be armed.
In the end, Japan refused.
Only after a ceasefire was announced, did it
send 6 small, vintage wooden minesweeping ships.
Even this was controversial back home.
The international community was furious.
Instead of sending forces, Japan contributed
cash — $13 billion, or 20% of the total
cost — though it stipulated the money could
only be used for “non-lethal” purposes.
Yet, with zero casualties to the U.S.’
over one hundred, it didn’t sit right.
Japan was accused of “checkbook diplomacy” —
paying money to dodge its obligations rather
than doing the “noble” thing
and putting lives on the line.
In truth, its assistance was far from
necessary — the victory came easy.
It wasn’t about money or
need. It was about fairness.
Japanese politicians chose to
obey the will of voters, who
opposed the war, but, in doing so, lost a
great deal of international credibility.
But the lesson stuck.
Ten years later, on September 11th, 2001, it took
the Japanese government just forty-five minutes
after the attack to set up a task force
and declare its full support for the U.S.
Within a month, Japan had passed
an unprecedented law that would
later allow boots on the ground in Iraq,
despite popular opposition and protests.
Since then, its troops have been sent to Cambodia,
Mozambique, Rwanda, and a dozen other countries.
But this is not quite what it seems.
The government only managed to sell
this dramatic shift in defense policy,
at least by Japanese standards, by imposing
insanely strict restrictions on itself.
The law only permits deployments
of up to 2,000 troops,
only for UN peacekeeping operations, and
only if five specific conditions are met.
The Japanese Self Defense Forces are
forbidden from infantry tasks, including
doing things like collecting weapons, and can
only operate in areas explicitly deemed “safe”.
Japanese troops often require dedicated
protection from troops of other nations,
which is sometimes derisively
labeled “babysitting”.
They arrive only after bullets have stopped
flying, leave at the earliest sign of trouble,
and because they’re forbidden from protecting
allies, are sometimes more of a liability.
None has ever died on a mission overseas,
and a single death would instantly
trigger a crisis back home.
This solution, in other words, narrowly satisfies
both parties — the public and
the U.S., but only marginally.
The trouble is that the two opposing forces
continue growing further apart over time.
Contrary to expectations, young Japanese,
even without a visceral memory of the war,
have not waned in their cultural
inclination towards peace.
Yet the American public,
and by extension, decision-makers,
increasingly demand more from its allies.
And while accusations of unfairness reached
a fever pitch during the Trump presidency,
they are by no means new.
Whoever the president and whatever the global
circumstances, Japan faces the same basic dilemma:
Public opposition prevents it from ever
taking control of its own defense destiny.
Yet, only one country can fill
this hole: the United States.
In short, Japan has one option, and one
option only. Who wouldn’t be anxious?
If it were ever threatened with war, it would have
no choice but to hope for protection by the U.S.
That is, except for one, very last
resort — the nuclear option, if you will.
In this bonus video, I explain how
Japan could acquire nukes — in a pinch.
You can watch this and other entirely
exclusive bonus videos on Nebula,
the streaming platform built by and for creators.
Some of my favorite recent Nebula Originals are
Legal Eagle’s Bad Law, Words Good,
and Second Thought’s “The New F-Word”.
Best of all, you can get access
to Nebula and CuriosityStream,
home to great documentaries on
history, nature, and technology,
like this one looking back at
WWII, together for just $15 a year.
Sign up by clicking the link
on screen now and get both
Nebula and CuriosityStream
for this incredibly low price.